good evening and thanks for joining us
tonight at 11 o'clock I'm Sasha Loftis
one local Family Sharing what led up to
a fiery situation in Summerlin and
neighbors had to act quickly to put out
the Flames 8 news now reporter Madison
Kimbrough joins us near the 215 in Alta
with a story you'll only see on 8 News
Now
residents in this Summerland Community
had quite the scare the other night when
someone illegally set off fireworks that
caused a small but aggressive brush fire
it's huge it's on the ground and smoke
everywhere Ryder Hong and his mom Trina
taking an evening stroll through their
neighborhood when they heard a loud boom
and met with Sparks in the sky it looked
like the fireworks that you can see on
July 4th a villa of smoke filled the air
and then they saw this it was kind of
scary yeah uh it was like I said it
could spread and it did spread I tried
using my water to like put it out it's
not didn't do too much but more people
came and then we all worked together to
put it out like fellow neighbor Eladio
canebano who stepped in to help as he
lives right behind the wall where the
blaze erupted I want to grab some water
a gallon thing some water I threw it you
know over the fence it was really scary
because it really was so close that they
felt like gunshot as for who did this
Trina has her theories I don't think
this is adults work I think it's all
kids doing it and they think it's fun
but they didn't realize the consequences
that could damage all these homes and in
a statement obtained by eight news now
from our local fire officials Fire
Marshal Robert Nolan says quote the Las
Vegas fire and rescue Department would
like to remind Valley residents that
legal fireworks those that have been
tested and approved as safe and sane by
the Southern Nevada fireworks task force
go on sale June 30th through July 4th
any discharge of any type of fireworks
before July 4th is a crime and
punishable by a fine of a thousand
dollars in Clark County reporting in
Summerlin Madison Kimbrough 8 news now
Fire Marshall Nolan also sharing with us
that while their task force hasn't seen
an increase in firework use they have
noticed those who are using them are
lighting up earlier than usual this year